قالت وزاره الخارجيه اللبنانيه انها كلفت
بعثه لبنان لدى الامم المتحده بتقديم شكوى
رسميه الى مجلس الامن الدولي احتجاجا على
القصف الاسرائيلي لمناطق الجنوبيه لبنان
ووصفت الخارجيه اللبنانيه في بيان القصف
الاسرائيلي بالانتهاك الصارخ لسياده لبنان
وبالخرق الفاضح لقرار مجلس الامن الدولي
1701 اضافه الى تهديده الاستقرار الذي كان
ينعم به الجنوب وجددت الخارجيه رفض لبنان
استعمال اراضيه منصه لزعزعه الاستقرار
القائم مع احتفاظه بحقه المشروع بالدفاع
عن النفس
اعلن الجيش اللبناني ان وحداته عثرت على
عدد جديد من منصات اطلاق الصواريخ وصواريخ
كانت معدل الاطلاق منذ ايام في سهل القليل
جنوبي البلاد اضاف الجيش في بيان ان
وحداته عملت على تفكيك تلك الصواريخ
والمنصات وكانت منطقه سهل القليل جنوبيه
مدينه صور قد شهدت قبل ثلاثه ايام اطلاق
نحو ثلاثين صاروخا باتجاه الشمال
الاسرائيلي بينما عمدت اسرائيل الى
استهداف المنطقه بسته صواريخ
معنا من بيروت مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي
ايهاب ماذا عن هذه الصواريخ ومنصات
الصواريخ التي اعلن الجيش اللبناني عن
العثور عليها في منطقه القليله
ان ياتي هذا في اطار استمرار عمليات الجيش
اللبناني بالتنسيق مع قوات الامم المتحده
العامله في جنوب لبنان
بعمليات البحث في المناطق الزراعيه التي
انطلقت منها الصواريخ جاء هذا الاعلان
الجديد للعثور على الصواريخ
الاطلاق بعد بيانيين اخرين للجيش خلال
الساعات الثمانيه واربعين الماضيه اعلن
فيها عن العثور ايضا على صواريخ كانت معده
للاطلاق ليس فقط في منطقه صور في جنوب
لبنان وانما ايضا في منطقه مرجعيون التي
عثر فيها على راجمه صواريخ صغيره الحجم
كانت ايضا معده للاطلاق وهي تقع في منطقه
الشرق البلاد وتحديدا في شرق جنوب لبنان
الجيش اللبناني واصل ايضا هذه العمليات
بالتنسيق مع قوات الامم المتحده الامم
المتحده ومن خلال قواتها واصلت عمليه
البحث ايضا مع الجيش اللبناني وتقوم
باستطلاع المنطقه وتسير دوريات وعادت هذه
الدوريات الى طبيعتها بعد ان خفضت قوات
الامم المتحده العامله في جنوب لبنان من
حاله التاهب التي كانت اعلنتها في مواقعها
المختلفه في جنوب لبنان بعد ان ابلغت من
الطرف الاسرائيلي انه سيقوم برد على القصف
الصاروخي الذي انطلق من لبنان لبنان ايضا
لا يرغب باي تصعيد للموقف وهذا ما عبرت
عنه الخارجيه اللبنانيه من خلال الرساله
التي واجهتها
لمجلس الامن الدولي عبر الامين العام
للامم المتحده والتي قالت فيها انها لا
ترغب في اي تصعيد وانها استنكرت عمليا
اطلاق الصواريخ الذي وصفته بانه يهدد
الهدوء والاستقرار في جنوب لبنان لكنها في
نفس الوقت
حملت القوات الاسرائيليه والطرف
الاسرائيلي بتصعيد الموقف بشكل كبير في
جنوب لبنان واعتبرته خرقا للقرار 1701
الذي صدر عام 2006 والذي عمليا ادى الى
استقرار طويل الامد في جنوب لبنان لذلك
فانها السلطات اللبنانيه لا ترغب في اي
تصعيد لكنها في نفس الوقت تريد تثبيت حق
لبنان في اي رد على اي عمليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه على جنوب لبنان شكرا لك من
بيروت مراسلنا ايهاب العقده